anime i watch is good Isis I never
really got into as a kid really part
from Pokemon or I mean I watched Digimon
as we talked about Joe and just that put
me off Digimon isn't the most respected
anime that's got a die-hard fan base I
think he's part of that family
no no but I know I think I made a joke
about it and there's like a new season
people got pissed yeah I said I'm Awards
cuz it's like it's like a lot of
people's childhood right because I grew
up on Digimon so I mean I wouldn't say
I'm a die-hard fan but I definitely
definitely enjoyed it as a kid I played
the game I don't know which ones like I
did I'd like that they're like Smash
Bros knock off that was pretty fun I
think
Digimon Rumble arena was called they
made like three of them the thing stuck
in my English at least like brah brah
the English ones the good one what can I
say listen the Japanese opening it's
like the like the it's like a you
probably heard it's like that you can
oh that's a song yes did you do a monkey
they pull the Dragonball Z right we're
like Dragon Ball Z Japanese opening was
like actual pop love songs that English
one was just dragon dragon dragon well
that was hard but that was fine come on
come on I just love how it's like
alright we got a show called Dragon Ball
Z in the song bro that's like big brain
mouth I think the only is come get me do
you not remember this at all euro the
English trample living no I think it's
like we forgot that it's so epic so it's
like iconic though how did you forget I
think the one piece rap is like blocked
out openings for me the one I see I had
the I had the pleasure of not going to
play it you had the good